so let's imagine this scenario it's cold
outside and we want to make a nice hot
bowl of chicken noodle soup well we'd
probably need to get the ingredients
first we need some chicken bones to give
the broth that distinct chicken flavor
some noodles to add that starchy
component
carrots and onions to give some
sweetness and color and of course salt
and pepper to provide seasoning
all of these ingredients would come
together to make our chicken noodle soup
the comfort food that so many people
love
but this video is supposed to be about
cells you know those tiny things that
make up all living things on earth so
why am i telling you about chicken soup
well just like how each ingredient in
chicken soup adds something unique to
the soup's overall flavor and texture a
cell's different parts add something
unique and necessary for the overall
functioning of the cell
so let's take a look at some of the
structures inside a cell and see how
their functions come together to allow
cells to carry out all the processes of
life
so let's explore the parts of a cell
starting with a cell surface
cells are separated from their outside
environment by a cell membrane you can
think of the cell membrane like a
fortress gate because it regulates what
comes into and out of the cell and
contained within the cell is a
jelly-like substance that fills out the
cell and contains its internal parts
this jelly and all the structures within
it make up the cell's cytoplasm
unlike chicken soup the cell parts in
the cytoplasm are not just floating
around instead they're organized and
held in place by an internal structural
network
some of the parts contained within the
cytoplasm are called organelles
so what exactly are organelles well
organelles are small compartments in the
cell that have different structures and
functions the word organelle basically
means mini organ and just like how our
bodies are made up of different organs
that work together to help us stay alive
cells contain different organelles that
work together to get things done inside
the cell
for example these jelly bean shaped
organelles here are little energy
producing factories called mitochondria
so mitochondria use chemical reactions
to break down sugar molecules in order
to release energy that the cell can use
for other tasks
another really amazing organelle is the
nucleus you can think of the nucleus as
the information database of the cell it
contains dna which includes the cell's
genes
genes are special instructions that the
cell uses to carry out its functions
moving over to a plant cell we can see
these green organelles called
chloroplasts you might remember that
plants carry out photosynthesis
well chloroplasts are the organelles
responsible for this process
plants need food to live just like
animals do and chloroplasts use
photosynthesis to produce sugars that
plant cells use as food plant cells also
have a layer outside their cell membrane
called the cell wall which helps provide
structure for the cell
so as you can see there are so many
different parts that make up a single
cell there are many many organelles
present in cells way more than the
handful i mentioned in this video and
what's even more mind-blowing is that
these diagrams are only simplified
versions of what cells actually look
like and just to give you an idea here's
a picture of what a real cell looks like
so when we're talking about cells and
using these diagrams as references keep
in mind that these pictures are only
simplified models of the real thing
to wrap up this video on cell parts
let's revisit our delicious bowl of
chicken noodle soup that i mentioned at
the beginning each ingredient that we
added had a unique function that
contributed to the soup's taste and
texture and similarly our cell's
ingredients its organelles and
structures each contribute a unique
function that helps the cell carry out
all the tasks necessary for life so the
next time you find yourself in front of
a bowl of noodle soup just imagine that
you're eating one enormous cell now
isn't that something to noodle on